he is a nine-time grammy award winner
and the first pulitzer prize-winning
jazz musician his new album the
everfunky lowdown
it's available now on all digital music
platforms my honor
to introduce wynton marsalis winton
great are you in new york sir
it's such a pleasure yes it's a pleasure
to talk to you thank you well
and to you two uh so but now you
were i was worried that you might have
been affected by the hurricane because i
know you have
new orleans no roots but no you missed
you missed new orleans
yeah were you there were you there for
katrina
no no i was in new york i've been in new
york since 1979.
okay but uh you know my relatives were
all there so of course all
anybody from new orleans that was a
definitive event
well listen i i enjoyed your your latest
so much um i love
the music i love the narration i thought
it was a particularly
uh important album in the current
moment that we find ourselves in because
we are in
sort of ultimate binary mode
where everything is right everything is
is in teams
democrat and republican and red state in
blue state and black and white and you
seem to be pushing
back against that and i find that very
refreshing
in in this atmosphere do you want to
tell me a little bit about your feelings
about making that album
yeah well we're being hustled um i think
every decade since the 1980s i've
written a piece that deals with america
our our social life
uh themes of class race
uh politics civics in general
and i've been driving across this
country i'm afraid to fly so i drive
everywhere and i know people
in all of the states and i've had good
spirited arguments with people
uh all over and this piece is entitled
the ever funky lowdown and it provides a
blueprint
to show us how to rise above populist
propaganda
on either side in the hustle and it
encourages all of us to have a much
deeper level of communication
and uh engagement with our largest
possible community
it's really the only thing that's going
to save us it's a collective creativity
you know the music satirizes the things
that divide us actually
and it encourages us to see an ironic
detail
how foolish a lot of this stuff is and
and for us to inspect very closely
what is going on and then fight for the
world that we all can
envision creating with and not against
others
yeah i i completely concur with that
message it's a difficult message to put
across nowadays
because people are on their teams and
they don't want to hear anything
different
when i criticize the left even though
i'm a liberal i hear it a lot like why
are you saying that
we're perfect they're evil and and i i
feel like that's not going to get us
anywhere because that's not the way the
world is
that's not the world the way the world
will ever be i know you signed the
harper's letter uh which was a letter in
harper's magazine a couple of months ago
it was organized by thomas chatterton
williams and it was signed by
150 very impressive people mostly
almost all of them liberals who were
basically pushing back against
cancel culture and saying we feel
stifled we do not want to walk on
eggshells anymore
we want to be able to speak freely think
out loud and not have to suffer
repercussions
and you're one of the signers and i
applaud you for doing so
well i didn't understand all about uh
who signed it i didn't know everyone who
signed you but i actually signed it
because there was some
some some black conservatives on on on
on the letter and i just wanted to say
yeah we should all speak to each other
but then it was a
you know cancer culture and all these
things are a bizarre form of imitating
other elite forms of oppression it's
like black listing mccarthyism salem
witch trial so on
people who have been victims of a
certain type of oppression tend to
create that same victimization when they
get the chance to get some agency
it's not uncommon it's just different
forms of attempting to keep people quiet
when i was growing up my mama whenever
she really didn't want to hear what you
were saying she would say boy
why are you talking now what are you
talking about
it's not what you're saying yes that you
shouldn't be saying
anything so the public space now is is
in a deal with people trolling people
being paid to be on the internet
people are dedicated to shutting
everybody up and what we actually need
is a deeper dialogue a richer dialogue
and as a jazz musician
that is our art you know we have a ours
is the art of listening and of
co-creation so it's
and we have a certain type of a live and
let live culture i play with all the
great musicians
art blakey you can name them and that's
the main thing that they were teaching
and you have to learn how to listen
listening is a skill that you have to
always uh
develop and work on and improvisation
conversational improvisation just
letting conversation happen
i think it's something that we are
greatly lacking and also i think
people talk about well we have to reach
across the aisle yes we do we have
republicans have to talk to democrats
and democrats or republicans but also
wouldn't you agree we need more more
dollar like within our own
groups within the group within the left
within the right talk to each other and
if you don't agree that's okay too
well you know groups tend to be like
gangs
yeah and you know our game works you're
with us or you or you're
against us right and that's that's what
the funky lowdown is about
and normally with gang with gangs what
they do is you have to commit a crime
against someone who is innocent and that
that bonds you and uh you know this is
actually the time to speak against the
the
whatever we've been doing has not been
working so instead of us having a vision
for our country instead of us having
things that we are actually working on
it is a constructive
uh you know we're busy we're busy
arguing
and fighting with each other and trying
to try to now you know of course
uh stuff like police violence is a prime
example of what we're talking about
the supreme court in june didn't want to
see
nine cases of seven or whatever it was
dealing with with uh with qualified
immunity that doesn't mean that that
would have changed
the state of things but it's just
interesting that the country when
everybody is in the street talking about
it
obviously it's a a tremendous problem
that went under the radar
nobody said anything about it the
highest court in our land saw it
so you start to get a kind of
anti-reason
and uh when things that don't have
leadership
which i'm in this moment we don't really
need a centralized leadership in a
strange kind of way the fact that we are
decentralized
is helping us survive not becoming like
any other place
this is despotically ruled uh so you you
do have a kind of
a back and forth but but you know
this this stuff just being talked when
was the last time a majority of 300
million people
needed to call some police for something
i've been up and down the country and
i'm saying if you could get 400 people
looting in chicago
and they represent millions of people
and it's not i'm speaking of something
that the writers trying to use in their
campaign richard nixon already used this
tactic
oh you know willie harden these things
work it's a part of every funky lowdown
you know that's what mr games says you
have to identify
some other and then create a problem
with them this far beyond what that
problem is
and then you've got to defend yourself
from them caesar
with with the gauls that were not to
toggle wearing guards but there's some
galls all the way over here that we've
got to go attack these people
y'all don't understand what they do they
eat their babies
they do stuff you don't want that stuff
here so you know
these people are going to be in your
house next week when's the last time
those people were in your house
you know how you're going to pick on the
poorest most disenfranchised people the
most under attack
and they're going to be the enemy of the
united states of america
hey man this and it's uh
you know the question for this for this
election is going to be will the large
group of white voters
that have been manipulated down through
these years with the fake law
of race and white supremacy reinforced
by whites and blacks and whoever else in
hollywood in the general
media can't make enough pro uh products
to sell to you making you believe this
stuff
one is that large body of people who
never owned plantations
who've been poor their entire lives
who've been struggling in this country
to get ahead
when they're gonna finally wake up and
realize that money and power is the
issue
and that the people they continue to be
directed to attack
have neither of the two and they don't
have any
they don't have the ability to actually
do anything you so focus your gaze on
who is actually
exploiting and manipulating you and
those people exist on both sides of the
coin
focus on that you know it's not poor
black people with no agency in the
culture
we have to remember you know racial
discrimination has always gone
hand in hand with labor and class
and you know this is where black people
and a large number of white voters have
a common cause
remember most of the lynchings were not
because a black person looked at a white
woman and whistled at her
it was because somebody requests a fair
wage
that's the truth of what of the of what
the numbers are telling you about this
so
you know to the traditionally exploited
mass of white americans
the other funky says keep your eyes
on the cash register and don't look at
the people staging the fight in the
store
and and we're going to be all right if
we can manage to get a very powerful
coalition
of those in whose interest it is to see
new
ideas about what our country has come to
the forefront
i am so glad i got you talking on that
because that was just
amazing to hear and uh more like that on
the album
i recommend it highly i thank you for
doing this it's an honor to speak to you
thank you
and i hope to see you soon die in some
day in person
uh here and in can't wait okay thank you
can't we thank you very much we got a
lot of promise out here
let's lead